[Music]
you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out
what happened the senate this week
passed a bipartisan bill
to promote new technologies including
artificial intelligence and robotics
what could go
wrong according to a recent article
a new dynamic of the republican party is
that most candidates have to embrace
conspiracy theories
even worse they all have to embrace this
haircut
why why i want the
oh i want the oatmeal oh
mitch
please
a town in west virginia this week hosted
an international water tasting contest
an international water tasting contest
or as white people call it
a cook-off
authorities in kansas arrested a man
after he allegedly attacked a grocery
store worker
during an argument about chick-fil-a
sauce
and it's a good thing they caught him
because he was about to dip
oh man when you're black and you get
your own little show
and you get to do black puns
oh my god he's gonna fill up your heart
yeah
according to new research elephants can
suck water into their trunks 50 times
faster than a human
can sneeze that story again scientists
have given up on cancer and they're just
out there having fun
bless them this is bed bug awareness
week
unfortunately your landlord doesn't
celebrate
and finally the national geographic
society announced this week that
the planet has a fifth ocean it's frank
well what happened to billy billy ocean
the he is the fourth ocean he's the
fourth ocean pacific
pacific atlantic india indian
billy and frank that's them that's them
and that was the monologue tarik did you
like the monologue
i did it helped me catch up on the news
well get ready cause here comes more
news for that ass
it was announced this week that
billionaire jeff bezos and his brother
mark will take an 11 minute flight next
month
to the edge of space yeah yeah who cares
oh who's that it's me jim bezos
i'm jeff and mark's other brother screw
those guys they're freaking jerks
wow you're jeff bezos's brother
what i don't seem smart enough to be
related to a billionaire you know screw
you too amber
whoa whoa jim bezos why are you so angry
because jeff and mark never include me
and stuff ever
i'm sick of it i'm a bezos brother too
but did jeff ask
me to go to space no
did you guys have a falling out or
something
your guest is as good as mine growing up
we were the three amigos i mean we were
as close as brothers could be
and then one day jeff just stops
returning my calls and
so does mark i don't know i don't get it
when was that
it's right around the time that this
photo was taken
notice anything yeah i do
i knew you'd see it that photo was taken
right before amazon hit it big
i guess jeffy boy thought i'd uh get
jealous or something i don't know well
that's not what i was talking about
jim did you ever think that jeff's may
be jealous
of you why would the world's richest man
be jealous of me because you have a full
lustrous beautiful pantene plus head of
hair
and his head looks like a condom
whoa yeah maybe you have the one thing
that jeff bezos knows all the money in
the world can't buy
well wait he can definitely buy one of
these it only cost me 150 bucks
that's a win never mind
i'm sorry i don't know why jeff bezos
hates you so much
it's probably because i stole all that
money from him
well probably no get out of here okay
hey take that wig with you
all right
now it's time for something fun great
idea it's been a while since we've
gotten to play a game on this show
and i miss it so i've come up with a fun
little game that you can play along with
at home
it's called buschemi or bird
this is the first ever game that asks
you to figure out whether a photo i show
you
is of renowned film and television actor
steve buscemi or
this one bird i saw at a home depot the
rules are simple
you just uh oh amber we have to put a
pause in this
check your phone a report out of florida
says there have been more than ten
thousand
covent variant cases and the state has
seen a surge
after memorial day all right
i guess buscemi or bird will have to be
pushed to another week
again this was supposed to be a comedy
show
with lots of gags and goofs and laughs
and spoofs that make you go whoa but now
the news keeps getting worse and i was
already fearing this
so no more jokes it's time for us to get
serious hey amber
that skateboard we ordered is finally
here you know for that sketch
john and kate plus skate sorry tarik but
that way too late parody is gonna have
to wait we gotta tackle some serious
news
oh okay
[Music]
kovid numbers rising means there's no
time for silliness
i can't wear funny wigs if the police
won't stop killing us
so no more smiling save your funny ha
has for the night time
i have to google what's up with this
pipeline
yeehaw partner well i reckon we got
ourselves a little brother
hey scotland we actually have to cut
this character
we want to do a speech addressing the
rise of white supremacy in the united
states
that doesn't sound very funny yeah it's
not but if you want you can come on at
the end playing a skinhead
can you be a cowboy skinhead no that's
ridiculous just a regular skinhead
i'll go shave i guess
[Music]
rocket ships from outer space might
crash and kill us all
and fauci says we might be wearing mass
still in the fall
california had its 12th mass shooting
did you know
that number's probably gone up since we
wrote this days ago
i'm a singing soda and i'm shaking my
can
hey no sorry corinne
we actually have to cut this sketch
there have been some really awful things
happening in the news so we got to
address them
you can go home but i learned an entire
broadway
dance number for this sorry i'm not a
dancer
it took weeks can i just like just show
you a little
just no corrin put your arms down it's
time to get serious
one day things might simmer down and
then we'll all get silly
we'll finally shoot that bit we wrote
with dunk tanks full of chili
but till then we'll do good with all the
power we have harnessed
and use our show to lighten up the
darkness uh
amber scotland's just got shot
yeah apparently some real skinheads
didn't like his impression of him
oh we can't do anything on this show i
have my own youtube channel now
yay be sure to subscribe for a lot of
show clips and a lot of digital
exclusives
and a lot of this